[Music]
good evening everyone welcome to our
lecture about chess and checkmate in the
Romantic era of chess and here we do
Grandmaster al-sham already buddy the GM
resident at the st. Lucia's Club and
here we are with the games from the
Romantic era let's first understand what
we're talking about what do you mean by
Romantic era anybody knows any idea
Ashish excuse me
okay that can't be romantic but Romantic
era there is an error that there's a
word that does that distinguish Barrie
distinguishing war there okay which era
is that Romantic era when is the
Romantic era there was a place David you
have to narrow it down a little bit so
pretty much until the match our Stanisic
Richard who knows when was that
who knows when wasn't matter you know
the quarter what's that yeah I said that
in the last class but you listen good
but which year was that 1886 Ben Simon
then the man in the arena okay yes 1886
was the match between the cathode and
stained it's that was different three
different cities including st. Louis so
it was New York st. Louis and also in
the New Orleans the the hometown of the
Paul Murphy changed insisted on having
it there so so that until then by the
beginning
usually the the trade market the
important point is the London 1851 the
first ever tournament
well I was there were matches before
that they were not a tournament before
that
the once they have 16 players guess what
they did they had 16 players how hard
did they have the tournament no that was
a double elimination yeah after the
first one actually did last 8 they were
playing double elimination and yeah so
that we're talking about a very short
period so now we have to talk about what
else okay they just alright so let's
talk about the characteristics of the
games now so this period is the same
period as romanticism in Europe right
it's it's post-enlightenment era I think
if I'm not wrong if I'm if I'm wrong
please correct me but I think it's post
enlightenment enlightenment era where
the Romantic culture music and
everything is just romanticism was
taking over everything and chess was
also an intellectual activity that was
affected of course by the theme that the
the actual evolution of thoughts at the
time so they were doing number of things
in chess you were saying used to start
with with it what did you say what kind
of chess they were playing attacking
okay there are a few terms I want to use
uncompromising it wasn't only about
winning a tournament nowadays if a GM is
learning a tournament he's one point
ahead of the field and he has white in
the last round they tried to dry it down
make it draw win the tournament because
you are there to win a tournament not in
the romantic era you show up at the game
you play for the beauty and winning the
game that's what you play chess for
there was different meaning into the
game what's that
that's what they're oh well well I don't
know but anyways anyway so there were a
number of good there were a number of
tournaments of London in 1851 Vienna
1873 there's another Vienna
that's the quor'toth one and these are
the three important ones and there's
another one that changed one which I
cannot remember which was that I didn't
search that one but there are four
tournaments and then finally the Vienna
73 was won by Stennis there's another
one also won by sneeze but recruited
wasn't there and Socrative won the
actually can't shake this one let me let
me just let me just bring this record
game it's London 1883 so London 1883 sue
Carter won this one as 73 was won by
Stannis there's one torrent between
these two which I did not cover which I
did not look at the tournament and that
one was won by I think she stands
bazooka it wasn't that tournament and he
wasn't also in 73 1 I start with 73 won
the game between was that no no no this
is the one black burnished things so the
the Vienna 73 was a two horse race
basically between standings and
Blackberry the funny thing is that these
two guys paired against each other
the very first round and the way they
were giving points to players was very
very odd so that each player there was
hopeless round-robin but they were
playing one game at a time
they were playing three at least three
games against at least two games against
each other you know why the first person
scores two points wins so if a match is
won you win the first game and if you
make two draws then what do they do they
give one zero for the guy who asked who
had one of game and drew the other two
so if the one will win and then win
there will be one one this the three the
third game would be basically a
tiebreaker because if they would drawn
the third game if they would have drawn
the third game then the match would be a
tie
that's how so and now the next question
if it's one and a half half and you win
again on you win two and a half half
what will be the results still is still
one zero which is a bit odd right
because that I mean the percentage you
score should mean something but it
didn't mean you think but I was okay
that being said first round blackburn
players against change so this is the
game one and we see how they how well
they knew to attack in those days so
black wouldn't demolish tons in this
game so let's see the Australian system
so he is reinforcing the knight on c6
and he wants to put the bishop on the
diagonal putting pressure on the center
that was his philosophy of playing
basically d4 takes takes this is
considered simply benign nowadays 964
now I don't know if g6 is a good move
here or not I have not looked at it yet
because g6 is a and you can't put
pressure on the knife and d4 okay and
since we're talking about classics
anyways you can check the match Larsson
Spassky I don't know which candidacies
was and spec and Larsson adapted this
setup and won a very beautiful game
against Spassky so you can check that
game Spassky was playing just for a I
don't know he was just randomly play d4
which is not such a great move so the
best way to play is to play C 3 d 4 of
course right trying to have a massive
pawn Center d4 it takes d4 Knight 64 954
but it also makes sense right you want
to replace it with the other light and
open your bishop and since you have less
space because given what I already
played the move d2 to d4 white already
committed to again what is already
committed to have one pound less in the
center i would not von Paulus because it
traded upon my god but he has more space
book is committed to the default score
so he has more space so 964 Queen takes
and he played knight c6 if Bishop takes
c6 why do you take back with a deep one
not with the beef on because you want to
trade the quays off and enjoy having two
bishops and your pressure would be
immediately in the game just takes
ridicu the deeper not to the people
so he played Queen d5 Bishop d7 I'm not
sure if that's the best mo for example
you can maybe play Bishop before check
if c3 now back to e7 taking away the
square from so maybe this is maybe
better and I'll back here now I take it
with this square from the night and if
we shall be to I just can if Bishop d2 I
just can castle because I I don't mind
exchanging right because I have less of
a space right when you have less space
you are fine with with exchanging
material or minor pieces move basically
in this case because heavy heavy pieces
is a kind of added question at this
moment by the way my notes on this game
is purely my own my own notes because I
thought at that at those days there were
no engines it was just human thoughts so
this is my thought as a GM player and I
did not check it with an engine okay
there should be seven okay that was so
fish every seven we play it nice c3
Bishop f6 Bishop d2 who is the head in
development who has more space oh yeah
what has one problem which is what is
what let's say say to me after ID ID I
didn't hear you what do you say
yes exactly exactly castle long castle
and a six now I mean you don't want to
take that night do you wish it goes back
and he plays d6 so I'm gonna win another
temple right with the move Bishop e6 so
black is fine now now Part F for g6 okay
this is a bad move
I was thinking probably the move Knight
before harassing this Queen and after
Queen to there maybe c5 so little bit
problematic Bishop c4 runs into b5 and
I'm preparing the move b5 and Bishop to
e6 if I go Queen to h5 I probably can
take and now you have to take the B part
because Bishop takes the knight excite
to check right so Bishop the pawn takes
and I can't take you I use my I lose my
night so I have to go back I think this
is interesting to say the least but I
don't think like Black is worse here
obviously he has to still deal with a
lot of issues but I don't think like is
worse
all right so g6 maybe prepare them of
night before so and now but Blackburn
okay we draw is Queen just in time
especially these have another temple
losing I mean the position is very sharp
it calls for drastic measures you have
to go for it something night before we
should be six something you gotta do it
be five
you cannot just sit because it's very
sharp because either side castle the
opposite side today I haven't cast in
the same side so as for its file opening
the files is something that will happen
soon and white has black has already
committed to this move g6 which gives a
hook to to white so white has a clear
plan black doesn't the pawn white pawns
haven't been pushed yet so it takes us
some time to reach out to them that is
why they said don't touch your pawns if
they don't touch the pawns in front of
your king especially when your opponent
casts about the opposite side super 57
h4 h5 now and do not play do not push
the pawns on the side you are weaker
which is in this case your King side why
because you're under attack the more you
push your pawns unless you are building
a wall that cannot be broken down which
in this case will be actually shattered
if you want you should not touch the
pawns on the side of your king you
should could your bad I think he should
have played b5 now after h5 what do you
think then any questions so far
anyone silence complete silence okay
g4 okay
any other ideas opinions f5 gives away
the e5 square to the Knight g4 it's good
g4 I want the edge file so g4 Blackburn
didn't hesitate to place both hope it
sticks g4 let's go that's five huh let's
get rolling
this should be six takes takes now
what's the easiest way not we have to
concentrate our power or our army for
the final attack right how do we do that
if I buy go Bishop f5 maybe although he
plenty five which is not bad but in it
complicates matters
I see that you saw them move I think
Luke tg1 is the best mode if not before
I go Quinn g3 Quinn v7 now if I take on
g4 i I will get I'll get my Quinn trader
which substantially reduces my the power
of my attack I don't need to do that I
go to catch for now I take take and then
I'll have a triple I will triple my
heavy artillery along the G file and
that's just impossible to to face so
Bishop takes c3 BC Knight takes a to
just king d1 doesn't matter our king is
safe but after Bishop takes d4 Luke
takes e4 back takes on g6 with g7 it
just destroys everything
I believe why didn't you keep the pawn
to create this thing what what she here
take that I mean I'm starting out this
is this isn't made coming here yeah so
let's make few moves okay this and
Queenie eight ninety nine ninety five I
think in this moment he should have done
something like maybe D take C file or
something but this this was bad this
Queen f7 was bad this losses how so
what's that
I mean we say romantic but not that
dramatic
keep looking guys I believe if I run the
engine probably Blackburn played like
the engine probably this moment they
knew how to checkmate in those days
then you think not g5e I mean I would be
delighted if I could plug my nitrogen
[ __ ] just that's illegal
I might have six check well that's
possible right I mean I'm trying to get
rid of one of the defenders right what
happened what what what happens after it
takes takes on f6 and what does these
are just there I'm suppose I don't take
the powerplay I don't know
rook f e8 Bishop f5
take on f6 now
any comments just
zc4 I just made a comment about that to
undecide that you're under attack and
you're you see you're attacking the
likes King right you're trying to
checkmate
so you're wicked on the other side
naturally you cannot have it it's how it
hardly ever happens unless your opponent
really screws up that you have advance
on both sides that you're winning if you
play in either side so this tactics
aside you're weaker so you're not going
to really benefit by moving by playing
on the on the Queen side you don't want
to really undermine your own King five
no but I think I just take on d5 and
you're forced I mean I'm up a piece
actually and there's a bishop I thought
you take back and defy when I was like
oh wait a second the bishop is on T two
what's that ninth of six mission of 6ef
six and then I just say look Fe eight
Bishop f5 th value a queen takes f6 King
f8 Fe C I mean that's okay you give it
to laughter that's okay the worst is
that it's not right - what you're not
you're not playing the game it's been
played a long time ago don't worry about
it
yeah well the problem is that after it
takes on d5 punished for you I take the
rook as well - and then I say I give up
more material do the thing is that so
Knight f6 makes sense after Bishop a5
okay if I go to be eight I think you can
just cut roopd g1 and then take this
pond or maybe or maybe I just can't go
here no I cannot touch that punim f6
right you can't touch this you should
see three coming right so I take on g4
and once I open the default that's game
over right can we agree on that good are
we good are we good up over there then
good fantastic alright so in the game
played Bishop a5 23 same thing point XA
- okay
he created some threats but then Bishop
c3 the bishop is beautifully placed here
there's no trick or checkmate here and
f7 is a big threat I look at it and f7
I mean who catch eight taken enough
seven chicken and then wreckage well
check - I'll go this way
so king f7 king goes for a sojourn but
it's a sojourn this it just ends very
fast much more here 23 first locate
shade
I don't know if anybody was in my most
painful losses on Tuesday night I well I
mentioned something from from an Iranian
he was a PhD was an Iranian champion and
he stopped playing chess long time but
he's a very wise man pity he died too
early
he said the winning move is not the one
he's not the best ball on the board is
the one that makes your opponent resign
and and here just you have to make your
opponent resign so the good enough is
and I understand if we're talking about
the Romantic era they it's all about the
beauty and the fairy tale and all those
things but also they were thinking about
the first price they couldn't after the
equivalent first price of that
tournament today would be $33,000 so I
mean I think for $33,000 was the
substantial amount of money back at the
time that I mean and now as you know as
well that they would they would be a bit
more cautious to convert so he just
check and then take the part they made
his coming they were not they were
romantic but they were not that romantic
as I said especially before 23 D 5 and
25 brookey 7 check is coming everything
is falling apart nice victory for
Blackburn when at his the person who at
his best days in those days his nickname
was black death look for his lethal
attacks brutal attacks yet although this
the account for this one I really
somewhere on the internet so you know
there's a chess historian named the
Edward winter and he would challenge
everyone for the accounts of things they
mention he's a very accurate historian
and he is very bitter toward people when
when they say things that he considers
inaccurate so if he will attack me one
day on this I really somewhere and I
thought the account was reliable so
just saying I'm not a chess historian
just I like just history but I'm not
just historian anyways so interesting
game but the funny thing is that so he
ended up winning all the matches til the
end and the last match he lost
horizontal and he got caught by he he
was he caught up
stallions caught up with him he won all
the other matches so he ended up with 10
out of 11 and and nowadays this how he
described each this guy's end of the
story this guy wins the tournament that
wasn't the case at the time they played
a rematch
and Sheamus won that one but I will not
cover it tonight I'll cover next week so
next one is secured against against
Blackburn ah the court won this
tournament with four rounds to spare I
think they were playing a double double
round-robin I think was 18 players I'm
not sure I can I can find a tournament
at the end yes London Knight 1883 you
wanna see that table first before I show
you the game or first the game invented
the table your pick 81 double
elimination 1851 1851 the first ever
chess tournament London in 1851 1851 yes
well the story is this all these people
came for the London export they had
planned for a month and they came
through they played three games and they
were eliminated I was like what I mean
it doesn't make sense so they thought
okay the next round first they're
playing for two out of three wins
whoever wins two out of three then they
made it three out of ten minute three
they made four out of seven next round
or three out of five and then four out
of seven and there it is okay these guys
are losing the campaig for the other
places you know for the last so who are
lost in the top eight they play among
themselves for the fifth to eighth all
right so let me just see this tournament
then immerse if they have a do they have
a database this is big enough I think
I think if I look at the games in 1883
there's a good chance that I don't need
more than that so just 1883
you see there's only 500 58 games played
in 1883 that is recorded so heist London
and if I get a cross-table 22 out of 26
so it's a 13 14 players round-robin
double round-robin what's that I don't
think there was there should be an N n
doesn't make sense to me Oh
anyways the point is that also I heard
that not hired I looked at the
tournament's rounds and zuker toured one
three rounds here on he last he lost in
last three games so he had 22 out of 23
and he lost and he already and as you
can see he exchanged finished with 19
points three points behind him I think
he had like six points lead or something
at the time I've not see five points
ordered lucky outrageous that month
points yet so he lost last three games
actually anyways let's get to see this
game so and as we see black flag was a
big guy at the time like he was one of
the top players but is that the game yes
see 46 ah that's not so romantic
romantic eras games already 45 opening
positions well wait few moves no opening
theory you know that Bishop doesn't
belong to e2
that you got D for Bishop d3 544 square
doesn't matter I don't think I don't
think the quarter cared I don't think
Blackburn was so much into where exactly
they just want some position to play so
this d5
actually this is now a very common topic
our position we play you can either call
this one I don't know I call it a usable
system because we used to play or
reverse usable system because you
suppose used to play this with reverse
color with d4 Knight f3 III b3 Bishop e2
and Bishop d3 so the idea is politely
for f5 and attack the King side the root
comes to f6 goes to h6 right I mean but
there's something missing here you have
to this Bishop is your power the sky up
side you have to
he gives the power to your attack here
it maintains this point over here right
so you have to protect him how do you
protect it maybe six years this is the
way so you prevent the move Knight b5 so
this looks obvious huh Blackburn one of
the top players of in the world back at
the time played Queen e7 not a good move
right it's not I can go Knight d5 okay
then I take that pawn on c7 besides I
can always trap the bishop with a three
so I played 94 Knight XD 666 90 to 90 f6
now this position wasn't that famous for
a long time until the Villisca finds
some very very cunning idea in this
position so if you're talking about
romantic chess Romantic era chess but
let's learn about superfluous scores as
well do you know what superfluous means
it means what David yeah it's my extra
so what is superfluous did not emphasis
Lewis right
how many nice can you put on it for the
can sit on top of each other right
so so in the gameplay they have three
but what's that
yeah might be one if that says that is
that is now it's a known theme I mean
when you teach chess I almost use it
everything of my have seen his positions
the superfluous to score but this was in
positional play but they were risky the
first time I was published so the point
is that now you're trying to play f3 and
that goes to g5 and then he pledged for
if I go h6 so that I have a score for my
neither you go have three here and then
you can take on d5 and after Bishop
takes you can go if or and you get the
center and you also have two bishops I
mean you got everything basically and
and if I could be five the problem is I
go F 395 and not just night covers this
is core so I can go D 5 D 5 oops
an exchange so they didn't complicate
the matter see he went there three night
62 Queen takes D to D takes e4 Bishop
takes e4 now what's our evaluation here
besides in those days there were knowing
about I mean okay they had some
understanding of the position of course
but they were not really evaluating a
situation what is will put the bishops
to are the king and black tries to plan
the C file but it's C fairly important
in this game what is important if you
were to neutralize Weiss advantage what
would you do what's so important
huh what's that I cannot hear - please
louder yeah so what could you try to
neutralize in whites position if you
were black say again how black would
neutralize whites play what is so
important in whites play that he would
try to neutralize as black
or some Bensimon
Albus you know looks very serious it may
not be but he looks obvious make him
laugh I play videos from cleanness with
movies and he laughs so that's that how
that's how it neutralizes seriousness
yeah be canceled shows no no no we do a
lot to that now so how do we neutralize
that how do we neutralize first you have
to identify what's so important in
whites position and then we try to
neutralize it
any comments it is black to move yeah
well the first one it makes sense what
is trying to play you for Bishop e3
force we go d5 you you lock your I mean
you you kind of block your Bishop but
also you prevent you for it's a lot of
effort not to play a four foot wide and
if I doesn't play a four there's no
attack right because if you go f4 and
try to bring the rook black was 94 done
right so Bishop d3 now what do we do
here
take your time
take it upon
and Queen before us so very important
love because if I go to ok you want
besides also when you go a five that's a
good move
you want to play Bishop h6 you want to
go Queen before and if I move my rope
you always have clean before and an a4
and you start activity on this side
before even why trust do something makes
sense
very good so in the game the move rook F
city was player okay even not even if I
was even stronger because now a four
takes texture okay - it's coming and
mission basics is a threat so if I go
for exam of this sorry then a four and
then takes and Queen comes to before
good
so he played Luke c7 I think this is the
very city this is a very serious
position on mistake why is it so because
look at the C file is that any SCORM can
exploit on the C file from black site
the bishop on b2 doesn't look so I'll by
the way just I forgot to mention here
networks have CA for pi white is good
and i-5 because you wanna go now Bishop
III so that's the Ciroc c7 now after he
for okay city five now white got this
space right and he still has his good
Bishop on the board and after rook 98
years he goes are for what can plaques
you simply nothing right there's no
square to go and see see all the squares
are controlled now he played g6 is it's
a good move now following our usual the
the theme of the period of the previous
game is a follow-up to that one as well
is this a good move or not
why what was a principal
that's okay basically saying that that's
exactly right right so if you were to
push upon which one will you push ready
say well if you were to push upon which
palm will you push if you were black to
push up on f5 yeah because the game went
g6 rookie three I know he played at five
I'm H 5 with 97 was the last chance and
then you try to rewrite the bishop to I
don't know somewhere here and just stay
still
maybe you start moving your King to the
center getting because now what is
trying to build right an attack like
this right so trying to do that but he
played f5 but the thing is what could
have had an attack had black kept the
pawn on g7 pushing it to have g6 now
gives white some Sun play EF 6 9 f6 ok
Queen f6 was last chance but not now
he's clearly worse I mean I can't go
Queen e2 I start with building my attack
the funny thing is that even now the
advantage is not so clear for white only
after Knight f6 is losing and why is
that because we got a hook remember
we're talking about the hook aha
high-five now 94 now what's going to
happen every one five minutes from here
till the end so this is the this is the
beauty of this game we locate the chest
in the backpack at the time wasn't so so
deep end they couldn't calculate
recalculate nowadays even an average GM
can see a lot of things that they were
not conserving back at the time but this
one is very deep he calculated the
entire thing sook rejoice that the his
brain was working well
and if I would if I were to give you a
hint I would say well I'm going to give
you a hint so to give you a hint I'll
say this is one of the crest deflections
in a in the chess history oh you have to
see the entire line to see the
deflection
[ __ ] you everyone a couple of ah not a
couple of five minutes to be fair and I
wrote again somewhere again if what
winter is going to grill me that's fine
but I read somewhere that he made him
move while Blackburn was walking so just
I thought maybe I can share that piece
of information with you
black Blackburn who is who was playing
as black you see was walking
been any comments no well slow learners
chess club that's his actual name okay
said sank the exchange and I said said
you're giving them a long time to think
yeah it's five four minutes more
okay so he's elaborated a little bit
this exchange will play tonight okay and
open up a menacing attack on the long
diagonal go for that mate yeah well the
thing is that where's the mate I mean
this is squirt has two defenders I mean
I I did this one just for two colors
here now you don't get to g7
okay
say what what do you think
rook C to e5
I get the concentrated
are they queen of seven and I've got
Coney of seven not ffaith
any comments been slow learners chess
club is really insisting on his previous
idea he's like no it's gonna happen just
press the F well okay I'm great to play
against him he can tell me his move and
I'll play out sure so rook takes e4 I'm
going to take it back with a deep on
then
this planet look like either at six now
renamed six now well I dare which one I
mean he can't play a move on I can show
because I have six we have seven I take
your bishop
Chloe I have some idea
it can't see through the entire thing
this is difficult fun this is like you
have to I believe you have to be 2350
2,400 to solve this puzzle but the idea
I'm looking for how you are going to
undermine blacks King it's all about
blacks King right if you decide huh
which one we should be three your queens
hanging you understand well when I mean
you first have to adjust it start with
the knight on e4 I mean that night is
really really causing some trouble right
and and if you don't do anything about
that black plays next movie takes f5
your attack is gone you're done upon and
that night will dominate the board so
you first have to take care of the night
what do you think man what do you think
what's your move
I don't know mine would be but I have
more suggestions
okay I'm open to listen okay when well
then the queen is hanging on d2 just FYI
we can cast that aside
what's that we can cast that suggestion
aside okay
David you got a month I'm still working
okay keep looking
okay I gotta show the answer so any any
more comments then I think it's coming
okay so we're ship takes t4 is for ski
okay
can we agree on that it's force do you
have to do that okay we saw it's about
this kink right now if I go edge 66 then
I I'm going down then it's gonna be
really bad you have to e5 Queen g5 and
then this is going down Bishop takes e5
we have six h4 that's a good question
actually I mean I can take on g7 first
you can take take
okay probably I get the winning end game
but that's it
no it's made actually I cannot now I
thought I have we should have six
checked but I don't now recap 1667 but I
can take home be seven and then take on
East exam of two points or maybe just
here you could I could go Queen g5 first
what's that what's really but
then I go rock g7 okay so first what the
thing is that what the park seats you
now he took on G texted seven check
that's good now if I take with my king
or with the Queen then the King is
really exposed and the checks with the
rook is game over so you keep like King
gets shade why play this move d5 check
and black the d5 now what this is the
great moment in the Romantic era the
greatest moment in Romantic era this is
the only tactic I know that I give to I
to higher level players for training
from that era and the entire tactic is
correct like there is no flaws in it
there's not mistaken it deflection I
said right
you're on the right track okay if you
have a look a fit but what about this
wow just wow huh if quintics before
or is this a
that's one mate and if I go here
I'll check me from the height so let's
go back where was I okay so Quinn before
couldn't before
now black plays rook eight to c5 now we
know we can move the bishop and so now
here it comes to the romantic part maybe
if you're in time pressure or something
you will end up okay just I move my
bishop I'm winning I'm taking on e4 and
it's gonna be made up material now it's
the Romantic era second deflection now
you have to take something there should
be five check King takes f8 Bishop g7
check if Queen takes back rank mate if
King takes mate comes a few moves
beautiful game right very very big let
me just show it to you again
so if Queen takes I've got Bishop takes
d5 check here and then these three guys
would checkmate because these three guys
are irrelevant because we said see file
is not that important
and with this and one of the victories
he had he won the tournament London 1883
with 22 out of 26 where he scored 20 out
of 23 the first 23 rounds and and then
he played a World Championship match
against who knows what was the result in
the first week in New York between
Stannis was that he was ahead for 1 or I
think maybe 5 1 something like that but
then they the match cut even in st.
Louis and then sue Carter in last 20
games never won a game and that was end
of his story of life he died few years
after
aromatic ended in a dramatic fashion huh
well thank you guys for joining me
tonight I hope you had fun and it was
quite romantic I guess all right you
have a good night thank you
[Music]
you
you